hums Gomez's pair 2-pack I'm still sick
my lights do this all right first game
super Wolf's HD get side oh I'm Joe side
well that's too psyched too psyched to
cyber health pack destroy it what okay
just I destroyed it
oh god it's the Nazis damnit anything
ouch god damn it they're crazy
take this Nazi scam ah [ __ ]
Oh headshot hey he's soaked away though
look at him
hey oh god no that's not Kawai not Kawai
filthy nasty scam what'd I tell you
about being Kelly if there was [ __ ]
Sugoi distill learn from him oh god he's
attempting a vault work oh god he'd nail
it almost where's my knife I need no I
got shot yeah what is up high again 360
knife shot Deming I mean fees [ __ ] take
this right in the in the not so dick
there we go that's how we kill Nazis you
hug them you hug them to death let's go
down amazing oh my god haha is awesome
I'm just gonna speed run it yeah
Oh shovel I love shallows oh my god I
got the shovel the legendary shovel so
now I can dig my way through this is
like minecraft oh my god how do I have
again you should been our home dog I
mean gun pop ass do it not take this
nasty skin that's where this is for
that's motherland god dammit what
happened I think that dog went to
another dimension
yup definitely did okay I'm out of ammo
shoveling time baby
as a great man once said if you're out
of bullets
then shovel those pictures in the crotch
I said that yep I said that you feel
free to quote me on that if you ever
need to I what else we've got 360
no-scope
360 shovel [ __ ] now I die or what there
we go
hey you're supposed to be dead thank you
you're coming with me to hell by the
[ __ ] oh god damn it
oh they got new had such luck y'all
[ __ ] yacht I should hop this game
reminds me of that one time I actually
know that this game doesn't remind me of
anything
Oh God oh I get it
look I was amazing uh hey super fatal
brofist 2014 I I waited so long for this
game took Matt finally oh my god the
PERT is that me oh but it that says you
are it oh it is me what I'm soaking what
hold and release oh I punch the [ __ ] out
of myself I always wanted to do that
damn it damn it oh you suck at this game
it's really hard
yeah damn it I keep punching myself I
swear on my mom I will damn it I'm so
close I have that beautiful duck face
beautiful even in games yeah pro-french
bro fit ha ha ha well that needs no
further intro that's me in a couple
years
not enough balls though or eggs whatever
the [ __ ] that it yeah it's a piece that
I've been captured by this horrible
monster Oh Satan we all know it's you
all right you can drop the charade
alright Wow the graphics is this thick
this is the PlayStation Fair
oh god shoot that can wait
hats while this is the best game I ever
played I'm shooting my love seeds and
they all can't handle it and I will now
kill myself for 4i oh my god hahaha
beautiful giraffe senpai
he loves balloons let's control with two
hands God what is this yay nailed it
whoa look alright there we go so cat way
the [ __ ] am i doing why do I have a
unicorn anyway yep yep that's what I
wanted to do yeah now of course I nailed
it I'm a giraffe what is it like what
does it look like Oh yep this is how we
walk in Africa Oh God oh that kills me
what if I land my face on it
what well I'm out of ideas yes tiptoe
that [ __ ] oh oh yeah nailed it where am
I what is this
ah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh now what I know it
well I never been so immersed as a
giraffe so I'll give it 10 out of 10
super ultra fighting oh simulation juice
station
I should probably go to a doctor I
should probably go do an actor I had
added the game no Ted this is awesome
ready fight what else
hahaha what if I do it to myself
no wait if I wouldn't get it back I will
fight you like it is this game you are
you sink your putti pot when I tell you
what you're not a pretty [ __ ] that's
yeah I got put if I were you doing pity
pot ha
that's rad pretty bad he's stupid hey
come at me bro come at me brick give me
a bit it's the best game ever oh my god
sad all you got bro just right let me
[ __ ] your face up you ugly [ __ ]
you think your pity pack I'll show you
pity pack oh yeah bitty pan yeah oh god
damn I [ __ ] that guy up ah [ __ ] well
it's up now I'm back I'm back I'm but no
I'm down I'm down that's just a small
step for fortify and [ __ ] hahaha some
truck did it in a day yeah yeah that bad
it did it did dammit
Wow yes I'm Nick I was naked for a sec I
swear to god I'm naked ah broke my back
nothing a little surgery and years of
therapy can't fix what am i doing over
there
stop it Pitts front-flip except that was
hot oh my god things are about to get a
little messy in here breasts don't watch
don't watch
let's go to an adventure here's right
hey babe sorry about fighting me before
come closer
we shouldn't be fighting each other we
should be loving each other do what you
want with me ah yes this is exactly how
I run this is the most realistic game
I've ever played
jump nailed it now that jump oh my god
I'm so fast
like I bet I am alright ready jump
yes what the hell are you doing hahahaha
what the [ __ ] oh my god this game is
ridiculous the soundtrack really speaks
to me too god damn it how can he be
faster on his anus than I am running
with my feet that's just not that's his
steroids he's using steroids
alright this game best game out of every
game ever gamed so I thought I thought I
was fine but yeah my throat is really
bad so I'll be back when my throat is
better tomorrow hopefully and that's all
for me for now leave it like I've
enjoyed watching brush it subscribe
convert today and as always stay awesome
bros thank you for watching